now while frustrations grow in nevada
about the demand for cobit 19 testing
the governor insists a fix is on the way
he is also reiterating how the pandemic
will continue to be handled in our state
the i-team's vanessa murphy here with
the latest from the governor and his
team
denise and brian more than half a
million at-home rapid tests are on the
way to nevada according to the governor
and the key word here they're free the
state is using federal covet 19 relief
funds to pay for them but you'll be able
to pick them up with no out of pocket
cost the governor making that
announcement today and continuing to say
nevadans will not face another shutdown
no intention of any
more additional mitigation measures
moving forward governor steve sisselek
says the state is relying on tools like
half a million at-home rapid tests which
are on the way they're expected to
arrive by the end of the month nevadans
will be able to pick them up for free at
at least 90 locations like libraries and
community centers throughout the state
while positive results from at-home
tests likely will not be reflected in
the state's case numbers the governor
and his team say they believe the tests
will still help stop the spread of the
virus if individuals who test positive
stay at home to isolate and notify close
contacts governor sislek also
acknowledging the surge in cases the
fastest growth since the beginning of
the pandemic the nevada hospital
association reports critical staffing
shortages and there are long lines at
testing locations like the samvoid
stadium but still governor sisselek
continues to insist there will be no
additional mitigation measures like a
vaccine mandate or shutdown we came
through christmas we came through new
year's we came through the rados raiders
playoff game we came through
making the playoffs we came through
several golden knights games you know
we've got a lot of events that are
occurring regularly those events
translate into jobs
it appears contact tracing is not taking
place i asked the governor about this he
says the state is relying on people who
test positive to notify people they've
come in close contact with and he says
resources have been moved from contact
tracing to testing and treatment as for
those free at-home tests we will let you
know when and where they will be back to
you